- All right, so, Justin,
what illusion do you have for me
and DJ Khalid right now?
- Okay.
- With your cute baby.
- This is my son Jackson.
He's making his network
television debut right now.
- I like it.
- I've been teaching
him some mind reading,
and we're gonna do that.
Because, listen, I've learned he loves
when my wife and I read
him books at night.
He loves books.
(Jackson babbling)
I know, I was telling 'em that.
But we've had so much
time to read, you know.
(Jackson continues babbling)
Here's some milk.
He's gonna get warmed up.
We burned through Dr. Seuss right away,
we kinda got into the sophisticated stuff.
Wuthering Heights, War and Peace.
I mean, like, we're digging deep.
(Kelly laughing)
And just last night,
my wife and I began what I believe to be
one of the greatest
literary works of our time.
I'm sure you'll agree.
TMZ's book of celebrity fails.
- Oh my--
- And it cracked us up.
- Didn't know that existed.
- Every page is a different celebrity,
and it's kind of all the
stupid stuff they've said.
Like, let's see, Paris
Hilton said, "What's Walmart?
"Do they sell wall stuff?"
- Oh, I remember that.
- I love this.
We're gonna do something with this book,
but first, my son has
made a prediction here.
- Okay
- Jack's prediction.
- Jack's prediction, okay.
- I'm just gonna place this
over here in the plant.
We'll get back to that.
- Okay.
- So, there's 129 pages in the book.
Kelly, give me a random
number between one and 129.
- 18.
- 18, okay.
So, we will turn to page 18.
Page 18 is, oh, nice.
- I can't see who that is.
- Tom Cruise.
- Oh, Tom Cruise!
There we go!
- Tom Cruise.
Could've been so many people, Tom Cruise.
Now, you're not gonna believe this.
My son Jackson knew that
you would pick Tom Cruise.
- Did not!
- [Justin] Oh, he knew.
This kid's a prodigy.
- All right.
- In his envelope.
- There's no way that
that envelope says Tom,
how in the hell would that?
Oh, sorry, baby!
Ears, earmuffs!
- He's heard, he's heard it all.
In this envelope, my
son placed a photograph.
You'll be impressed if inside here
is a picture of Tom Cruise?
- I'm gonna freak out!
I don't understand how
that's even possible!
- I'm gonna pull it out,
Jackson, here it is.
A photograph, one photograph of
Tom Cruise, at two months!
- (laughing) That is not Tom Cruise!
- No, it's not.
It's Jackson at two months.
Jackson at two months.
But he did know you would pick Tom Cruise.
That was a--
- Okay, how?
- That was a dad joke.
I'm trying to teach him that, too.
When he got dressed this
morning and put on his onesie,
he picked a very specific
onesie just for you.
(Kelly gasps)
- Wow!
- What?
- That's crazy.
- Put on a Tom Cruise onesie.
- That is so not, that's
not even possible!
- Tell 'em how you did it, Jackson.
- That's crazy.
- I can't even believe.
I can't see it, I'm so hot
right now, my pits are sweaty,
I don't even understand
what just happened.
Oh my gosh, you are so
talented and gifted,
or actually magical--
- Nah, that's,
that's crazy.
- And we just don't know.
- It's all the baby right here.
- [Kelly] That was crazy!